і день б'ють пулом вони ребра ваш кіпур
вона якін сівак чорноморського trauma шрам
чи ткою до неї на руках
про український активіст за станиці
луганську Олександр Дорохів
дасин йому жорстокий призначають і париже ти
впав про не ерік тому
про українського 300 яка рівно лнр
місяць незаконно у тремоло нато до тувалу
підвалах луганську область адміністрація
сепаратисти
був один виживу but in такий
руди в 32 за вежею він був напою
нами їх на краще ти соху вів знявши з собою
черви
і 5 на мага все вручну приховую я на тему
боті лижах
анапе від кайданів залу wingle прямо по
пензлики
сюди дарма що я ключі вся
акули with clip хоче вичавити на тему боті
і було так і мало не було чому
змі до малюка
я по темницю волос секс і так напружив
ло
ніж мя кабула лежать і було лежати вище
пісня-то вояку людини роуз підібгалася
андре нас апарати варто пустив її у до
будинку в желе pid контроль якогось
території з личі МВС і відкрила
кримінальне право Дженні за фактом
викладання дорохово зібрати з там і в
team за рикш туману
розслідування не сунулася розміститися
самих лечі пояснюють сіток на хіба
дроту шокових, що не злилися, де цей
досвід та сувої
у складі та проводу німота на
території луганської області за крима
місця луганська д за за передніми та даними
і вранці на всю дорогу не задоволені о 6
так ними і ритмів найбільше зазнав
вивернувся поту допоможуть гру травневе пекло
катиф українського хельсинського зі спилка
адже виправлю справі to cook with не разом
за 2к там Юлія Науменко
на провал до європейського суду у справлю
даною скажу відразу на дві держави росію
і україну як їх поважаючи війни ми маємо у своїх
бідах головний аргумент завершення
порушення обама державами кіль як
статей європейської конвенції справлю ден
і
краєм
не забезпечуючи україни, вона забезпечила б
speck у своїх room 1 і
над зараз не розслідуючи купа травня широкий
спектр повний важливий факт викрадення не
і коту ваню олександра хіба це гаваны
адже не порушив і кримінальну справу
за фактом готова не збоку русія
порушення конвенції у товщу води без
посередника зменшила люди ну свободи коту
вала його вранці та валуни людських умовах
прям уже його на проти ти сидиш біля крему
стаття європейської конвенції на
конвенції 4 з цього комітету руси ще
правда на захід адвокату в українську
олексинська спинкою заправлю ти на вигляд
побачить одні русь кафедра чину і
учасникам деяких обраних конфліктів на
території України УЗД скушним пояснюю
що за даними фактами slide повернулися від
у компетентних органів України захищав
одна причина я caspa цибулі я зазнав їх
у нас літо конфлікту на сході України
цукати справедливості європейському судді
виправлю ден і наш адвокат Юлія Науменко
вигадувалося їм різновид по видних scar цим
а взяти і до розряду вже транспорту
устюгів і ок заздрите їсти pl наді йшло
вже за написом тисячі заяв пов'язані з
студії ми на сході українців безчасткових
приставках він разу pro t2 тримав русі
це україни
циклони джином скажу про покликав мене
волею завдання тілесних пішло джей
засіки особливому ці брав і доля у
бойових дієт зубок старовин конфлікту
Олександр Дорохів
обізнані, що рішення європейського
суду у справлю ден та dvd cd до тисячі на
і менше 5 року в олівін готові багатше
здобута прецеденти коли та росією
україна на місце буде побачені на заході
на донбасі а ви уявіть якщо а той
момент її вигляд собі відчуваю годину фокуси
дива земна там перебувала 150 і до
200 за три чернець скільки людей у ​​залі
пройшло через тибет бали за спорідненість нас
їдять і мовчати чоловіки вірити в ти че
за нах тобто можна заступайся
зайняти мій тато заступиться поки активіст
перебував аполлоні
його буду і ніг розбомбив і ти первин у
Києву щодня проходить по вустах жодної
віруємо небесно сотники заглянув
про майдан, що коштував нову краху нам
україну та keep поважають та захищають права
та свободи громадян
віри в 1000 сама така роки Олександр з
чайним витрачаємо